Limited continuity is the heading these
are ideas that I have sowed the seed
about and talked about informally over
the last week or so but now it's time to
do this you know and what mathematicians
call a rigorous way we're going to get
like watertight detailed formal
definitions for all of these things okay
but that they came together either they
are quite a big idea so it makes sense
introduce them simultaneously this thing
here really kind of new notation I'm
going to read it out for you I'm going
to tell you how I read this and then
you're going to tell me what the numbers
so the way I read it is and I love you
to write this underneath so when you
refer back to this in like three or four
or five weeks it's been a while but you
touch this you be like oh yeah this is
what that we notation is talking about
the way I would read it is they'll live
in it that's what the limit is shuffle
the limit as X approaches it is case
three of x squared is so this sets a
limit X with an arrow towards three says
I'm approaching I'm putting in X values
because closer and closer and closer to
three and what I'm putting them into is
this particular function of you have any
function you like to just using this is
a nice simple example because we can
actually work this out as X gets closer
and closer to three what does x squared
get closer and closer closer to adds up
nine
okay so as the X values change for
example if an aluminum a calculator see
it excellent should point nine that's a
number that's close to three I don't
know what's your point nine squared is
but I'm about to find out two point nine
squared is eight point four one so I've
been to nine if I put in numbers that
are closer to three like two point nine
nine I get eight point five 401 and I
can get as close as I like that phrase
is actually really important the reason
why dying is the limit is because you
can get the data medical way of seeing
it the technical rigorously is saying it
did we can get arbitrarily close through
this number so if I say okay how close
would you like to get to know I want to
get to eight point nine nine nine nine
nine nine that's how close I want to get
you can give me an X values that'll get
that cooks or close up right or nine
point zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
one easier next day they can get that
close tonight and the answer is yes
there is I can get arbitrary close to as
close as I want now in this case it's a
bit mid why we introduce this notation I
want you to think back to when I
introduced function notation remember I
was like why are we talking about this
well we have perfectly good notation why
don't you say y equals quiet f of X in
this weird kind of idea which overlaps
with use of brackets and all that kind
of thing that's confusing
the answer was at least one of them was
you can talk about things like this if
you have a function where this is true
what do you know about the function it's
an even function you're going to have
line symmetry around the y-axis right
and accordingly I say this what do you
know about the function
it's an odd function is going to have
quite symmetry rotational symmetry
around the origin right right at zero
zero so when you have that function
notation you can talk about properties
that you
we can talk about before the same deal
with limit notation and limits in cotton
which is a new idea we're going to get
into okay so let me give you some other
examples for in this is example one so
here's the able to need to introduce a
bit more harmonization here so if I say
limit as X approaches infinity we're
taught that as a forage in the context
of graphene right so I might pay
something like this okay now this is
important as an example because unlike
this one right I'd like this example
where you could have got nine just by
putting in x equals three you can
actually substituted you you cannot
substitute in x equals infinity because
infinity is not a number it's a concept
it's an idea it behaves a little bit
like a number but in other ways if
there's not right
so you're like what do I do with this
thing the arithmetic of infinities is a
tricky thing that is not good to
discover this course but we can still
understand the idea as X gets enormous
this becomes one over and all the
someone wants one over ignore some boxes
now want you to notice how this fit into
this the function 1 over X if I want to
get to value like their point zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero one is
there an x value that can get to that
the answer is yes no matter how close
you get to zero arbitrarily close you
can find an x value that'll do that okay
but when you start think about this
function here immediately you come into
some problems so one of the important
things that this is you remember I said
you can approach and get really really
small by really really close values
below 9 and you can also get really
close above right so when you come from
one direction
I used to be able to say that name with
a strength effect anyway well when I
come from one direction all come from
the other direction you come to the same
value right what do you think about this
guy this is an important case they from
us you run into a problem you know what
this graph looks like you know what it
looks like right it's got two branches
right so what you say hey when X gets
closer closer to zero what does this
thing approach these sort of run into
this snag how do you spend it let's just
underneath draw the graph yes more
version is all over now
when X is approaching positive infinity
the limit is unambiguously zero there's
nothing else that it approaches okay but
when you get closer to zero well if you
try putting in positive values that are
close to zero like 0.1 or 0.01 etc what
are you going to approach you're going
to encourage a huge number
in fact now this is this is weebs where
it's it's similar but different
you can become arbitrarily close to
positive infinity right give me another
a billion a billion a Google anything
you like
I can give you an x value that will get
to that what over x will get up to there
okay so I can get arbitrarily close I
can get as big as you like that's what
happens when you put in 0.0001 or
whatever but when you put in negative
here 1 0 0 0 1 all those kinds of things
you do not approach negative infinity do
you instead approach sorry I said that
right dude I said these are colossal
yoga you don't approach positive
infinity you approach negative infinity
because it's dropping like a rock down
here ok
so therefore this as its stated has no
answer there is no limits me girls that
were the control limit doesn't exist so
however this content is still important
to us so we distinguish between
approaching zero for the positive side
like this or approaching 0 from the
negative side is review notation for you
when you put a plus sign in the index
right in the power a different work out
what our because it's not even number
okay what this means is you're
approaching zero from the positive side
that's from right to left
does that make sense so this is a person
from the right so therefore this is
equal to positive infinity
however if on the other hand I approach
from the negative side a lot of power
but it looks like one context but if I
approach it from the negative side I get
the opposites limits okay all right are
you happy that it yes full of limited
effectiveness was too happy yet remember
that's football tonight because I think
so I'm putting reading 3.01 what we put
0 0 0 1 or trick 1 0 0 0 0 0 0 1
I just put your numbers that are in box
3 because I can approach 3 from two
different directions right so I can
approach from I can approach from below
read that's one of the ways we say it
rather than from left or right you can
take from above or below and that will
give you these values for x squared
notice